oui je vous le répète il faut faire des
statistiques ethniques j'ai toujours été
favorable et je pense que la gauche est
d'une hypocrisie dans cette affaire
monstrueuse cet extrait date de 2015 et
pourtant le sujet est éternel et le
débat reste tabou en france statistiques
ethniques ces données concernant
l'appartenance ethnique d'un individu
existe-t-elle vraiment en france et
peut-on produire de telles données
réponse dans facture
[Musique]
il faut tout d'abord retenir deux
aspects importants contrairement aux
idées reçues les statistiques des
techniques existent bel et bien en
france les halles ne sont pas utilisés
pour recenser ou trier les français
plutôt pour réaliser des enquêtes en
effet lindsay pts interrogés les
individus sur leur pays de naissance et
leur nationalité
le but connaître la diversité de la
population mesurer les inégalités et
parfois les discriminations
depuis plusieurs années les
statisticiens ont même la possibilité
d'interroger leurs interlocuteurs sur
leur ressenti d'appartenance dans le
cadre des enquêtes trajectoires et
origines pourtant officiellement la
collecte de données dites sensibles
comme l'appartenance ethno racial est
interdite en france
c'est même puni par l'article 226 du
code pénal de cinq ans d'emprisonnement
et de 300 millions euros d'un monde sauf
que la loi permet d exception à des fins
de recherches scientifiques ou
historiques
et deux gendarmes veillent de très près
sur ces exceptions le rgp dès le
règlement général sur la protection des
données et la cnil la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés
en 2007 c'est le conseil constitutionnel
qui a lui aussi interdit le recueil
d'informations ethno-raciales noirs
arabes qu'il a déclaré contraire à
l'article 1er de la constitution
la france est une république indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale qui
assure l'égalité devant la loi de tous
les citoyens sans distinction d'origine
de race ou de religion
et blanc elle vouloir etes-vous
d'origine asiatique rapproche d'un
référentiel unique non à celle et ça ce
n'est pas autorisé par le conseil
constitutionnel en revanche le conseil
constitionnel autorise des questions
subjectives sur le ressenti
d'appartenance de comment vous
voyez-vous plutôt de telle ou telle
origine ou même plutôt de couleur de
peau blanche chaunois pourtant le
conseil constitutionnel a bien autorisé
certaines études qui peuvent être menées
à partir de données d'ita subjective et
qui tentent d'évaluer le contrôle au
faciès par exemple où l'accès à l'emploi
et au logement car ce qui est
normalement autorisé en france c'est
uniquement d'interroger les individus
sur des éléments objectifs d'identité
mais alors dans les enquêtes il y as
soit des questions sur les pays de
naissance des personnes leur nationalité
à la naissance qui permet d'identifier
les personnes dites immigrés même sur
les pays de naissance des parents
une statistique ethnique ça veut dire
voilà la pression que j'ai d'appartenir
à telle ou telle ethnie le lieu de
naissance de et par an c'est un élément
objectif que personne ne peut contester
qui est noir c'est très difficile à dire
parce qu'en réalité parmi les personnes
qui ont une certaine noirceur de paul il
y à des variétés tout à fait
considérable c'est une notion qui n'a
pas de sens objectif la notion de blanc
n'a pas de sens objectif également parce
que vous pouvez avoir des gens qui sont
tirées naturellement tout en étant
blancs eux relativement bronze et
d'autre beaucoup publ encore on va
distinguer les blancs français les
blancs français originaire de belgique
les blancs français originaire d'italie
enfin pour toutes ces raisons que ce
type d'enquêté très sensible et donc
très encadrée elle doit d'abord être
validé par la cnil le conseil national
de l'information statistique qui jugent
de la pertinence de l'enquète
puis elle doit présenter les questions
qui seront posées aux individus afin
d'obtenir un label qualité en parallèle
dans certains cas il faut obtenir
l'autorisation de la cnil
le tout sous plusieurs conditions avoir
recueilli le consentement explicite et
écrits de la personne interrogée assurer
l'anonymat à la source des données
collectées et que l'intérêt public
justifie cette enquête
est d'ailleurs dans les pays anglo
saxons adeptes du multiculturalisme les
statistiques ethniques ne posent pas
autant de problèmes qu en france au
royaume uni le recensement ethnique a
par exemple été utilisés pour évaluer la
mortalité liée aux qu'ovide selon les
origines aux états unis près de six
catégories raciales figure dans les
questionnaires de recensement qui était
établi tous les dix ans et cela leur
permet notamment d'identifier les
descendants de l'esclavagisme
attention car si nous venons de parler
de recensement aux états unis en france
ce que man l'insee ce sont bien des
enquêtes et ça c'est très différent car
en france le recensement permet de
compter toutes les personnes qui
habitent sur le territoire quelle que
soit leur origine ou leur nationalité
il se base sur des éléments objectifs
comme le lieu de naissance l'emploi le
sexe d'un individu il ne comporte aucune
auto déclaration d'appartenance à un
groupe ethno raciale car celle-ci
s'apparenterait à une déclaration
identitaire alors qu'une enquête elle
peut poser des questions totalement
subjective comme le ressenti
d'appartenance
prenons un autre thème qui est celui
d'un religieux nous nous considérons en
france que la religion relève du domaine
privé et donc il n'est pas question de
mettre questions sur la religion dans le
recensement mais ceci n'empêche pas dans
des enquêtes qualitatives d'essayer
petit banc de demander aux gens pour
aussi et d'abord l'évolution religieux
enfante a résumé l'insee même bien des
enquêtes ponctuelle elles recueillent le
pays de naissance d'un individu ou de
ses parents ou de ses grands parents
elle peut même abordé le ressenti
d'appartenance mais elle ne le fait pas
de manière systématique lors d'un
recensement annuel comme aux états unis
un seul territoire en france fait
exception et c'est la nouvelle calédonie
puis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale on distingue les communautés un
kanak des communautés européennes puis
ça a été totalement autorisée à la cnil
et pour le coup au motif de l'intérêt au
public ce statut particulier lié au
référendum d'autodétermination
fait que le recensement en nouvelle
calédonie comprend donc des questions
sur l'ethnie et le sentiment d'être
calédonien ou non ou les recensements
nouvelle calédonie ont cette question
sur l'origine ethnique des populations
sauf celui de 2000 cas parce que le
président de la république jacques
chirac est allé en nouvelle calédonie et
quand il ya vu qu'ils avaient des
questions sur l'ethnicité dans le
recensement il a interdit cette question
mais bien entendu on est revenu dessus
parce que effectivement il ya une partie
des financements publics qu'ils sont
liés à la connaissance des ethnies cité
pourtant ces fameuses statistiques
ethniques sont préconisées par la
commission européenne qui a déjà plaidé
pour un plan d'actions en faveur de
l'intégration et de l'inclusion et l'onu
va encore plus loin en estimant que cela
permettrait de lutter contre une forme
de racisme dit systémique
pourtant cette pratique reste
globalement rejetée par la tradition
française tous les politiques ou presque
la refuse nicolas sarkozy était pour
françois hollande a jugé inutile et
emmanuel macron l'a balayé d'un revers
de la main en 2020 alors que son ancien
porte parole avait rouvert le débat quoi
ça servirait d'avoir des 7 je pense que
si on pose le débat il doit nous
permettre d'abord d'objectiver les
choses on s'est toujours est un principe
d'universalité tous les citoyens sont
égaux devant la loi français pas une
addition de communautés qui se distingue
par des sentiments d'appartenance
ethnique et certains craignent de
banques en crise de la les verts taris
de favoriser ce type d'approché un sujet
des touches où
certains ont dit fond celui utilisé le
mot race parce que ça a compté racisme
certains ont même souhaité que le mot
race est ce plus de la constitution
destinée dans la constitution et en même
temps parfois les mêmes d'ailleurs avec
notamment la montée de l'idéologie walk
considère que le fait d'appartenir
actuel ou telle race est tout à fait
essentiel pour comprendre l'identité de
quelqu'un princial is et les questions
sociales est un véritable risque le
constat est partagé par les
parlementaires qui dans ce rapport de
mars 2020 estime que toute approche
autre que l' approche universelle est
susceptible d'entraîner des effets
pervers et de renforcer la conscience
raciale de certaines minorités tout en
occasionnant des frustrations chez les
populations dites majorité
pour les partisans des statistiques
ethniques au contraire cela pourrait
être un outil pour mesurer l'étendue des
discriminations mais comme nous l'avons
vu au début de cette vidéo c'est déjà le
but d enquête ponctuelles menées par
l'insee officialisé les statistiques
ethniques permettrait donc selon eux de
mettre fin à une certaine hypocrisie
alors que le débat sur la simulation et
l'identité française n'a jamais été
aussi vif